what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am rejoined by Sally
lamonico all the way back in the Big
Apple Sally how is you doing uh great I
love that you still think I live in New
York City that's how I'll always view
you you are the Mary Jane from there
guys go check out her short film she is
actively working on it date by day
chiseling away at that special project
and it's looking good what are we
watching today Sally we are watching the
critically acclaimed
sequel to grown-ups a very serious film
we reviewed it in depth on this channel
and you guys seem to enjoy it so we're
doing the sequel we're doing the sequel
we're just a couple months later did you
read about it because I may turn out to
read about it because I just want to go
in you know fresh Minds no spoilers for
girls no spoilers guys I said I want to
make sure all the surprises are kept in
store for this reaction exactly ladies
and gentlemen you know what to do go
ahead please leave a like that would
mean the world you can follow Sally on
her YouTube channel as always thank you
to everyone who has joined our patreon
page full-length reaction watching
alongs where you sync up with your own
copy for grown-ups available for super
sexy Rejects at our patreon cover a
whole bunch of stuff exclusively over
there as well you ready to rock you
ready to rock this I'm ready to rock and
roll and I'm also ready to grow up you
ready to hang out with our favorite
characters you know you remember Lenny
Eric Kurt Marcus yeah yeah you you know
are those all the real names in the
movie I can't remember the names I
didn't just look them up on IMDb let's
roll that intro
[Music]
growing up harder
growing up taller
than as wide as you can please
oh how rude and how real open the window
now
I wouldn't be whispering
oh no
oh closure
close your mouth
why didn't you try another way of
alerting your wife
[Music]
close your mouth at least you're already
in the shower this is the weirdest
cartoon movie
[Music]
yeah yeah one crazy ass one he's
a little girl didn't she also try to
drive a car in the last movie
[Laughter]
towards me
and back to you
give me that thing
no don't worry little girl this is your
fault
there needs to be a sacrifice you like
this guy
huh
come on come on man it costs 30 million
dollars to bring this deer to life
good though
problem solved
[Music]
well it's your fault is that your
broadness
see
my God
cheers
[Laughter]
yeah bro
oh my God this kid
that's right again smarty pants too much
breastfeeding
yeah
or a computer
he's got to learn some way
oh looks like a horse took a jump in
Ronnie's diaper
that is a lot of crap
oh my God that is gross you got a lot of
money
a job
is she a stay-at-home wife now
oh have the tables turned
oh my God it was a gift uh it's a poop
necklace
happy 20th anniversary babe
[Music]
oh
she forgot
oh that's cold
he's cute
yes King
it up
I'm not even a thousand percent sure who
you are
I'm gonna have to ask for a DNA test you
know because you just never know holy
[__]
no need
later hiccups what does he have a long
lost son that is exactly what they
established pay attention to the Deep
dialogue Sally no but I thought she
meant like new son not like old time
strike one
good news is you get unlimited amount of
strikes
how would you feel about
me
having another kid
another one if I buy one large pizza
Greg gets two pieces Keith gets two
Becky gets one you get one I get four
It's Kind of Perfect
what are you gonna diet oh
don't forget Becky's ballet recital at
11. I gotta go to that
you're gonna ask her out dad because
she's the hottest girl in school and
Greg is ugly so what he's fugly all the
guys in our family are fun
look at me and look at your mother I
mean it makes no sense only in like a
Hollywood movie or so
make the girl smile number two tell her
she has a nice smile say she has to go
out with you that night why that night
because it gives it less time to think
about how fugly you are it's not a bad
idea yeah actually
[Music]
I legit thought that was 25 minutes and
I was wondering why they were are you
serious I was really late to getting
that joke thank God there's no crazy
people out here
oh next Schwartzman
my wife's leaving me you seem like
you're a little extra out of it today
what's what's going on yeah I'm a little
medicated but I
but I feel worse
nice
I love Adam Sandler's friends
I love him in Benchwarmers that's my
favorite role he's ever played Deanne
happy anniversary Lenny remember isn't
that sweet sheep again
biggest get out of jail free card in the
world yeah exactly man your fried
mindset
oh my God I love you
that sure you do
deep down
[Laughter]
I relate
because you're married now so a first
night of summer party
I'm a little crazy oh last party I had
was senior year in high school that was
like the best night of my life we all
hooked up with chicks come on why not do
that again hook up with chicks what yeah
ew he's gonna eat it isn't he
how could he keep a straight face
um does Leonard ever talk about me
he used to be my boyfriend
no way what when did you guys go out
sixth grade we split a piece of bubble
gum at recess
oh God
do you like my hair better never red or
a headband
that's what I wrote
Barrette and that was his response oh my
God
and she's kept it ever since
I could see that being you in a few
years Sally sure
sounds defensive okay not a guy from
guy from here like six months ago
at the class we're at the class
how was your last ride in before the
summer Nick
only a half a day and a half a shirt
right what I said he wants to wave
goodbye okay here you go
thank you for breakfast mommy we are you
coming by to watch Days of Our Lives
later
good to see you did Mommy make the
boo-boo go away
tell the wife don't tell the wife what
what
oh watch this
oh God
ow I hope that was a dummy and not a
stunt person
why
[Applause]
would you bring this [__] monster to
yoga
I don't know I would not do yoga that
day
worst day John love it might just have a
mop it's carpet up on your feet and
let's take a deep breath
oh my God he's a pervert janitor and now
let's Shimmy Shake the shoulders back
and forth shake them
really fast that's too fast now
I hate to see it is so uncomfortable and
bend over as low as you can go relax the
wrist and slap that right butt slap it
like no one's questioning it out but
like get bent bro I think this is
empowering for women is it yeah
I think I've done it in one of your
videos
a long time ago yeah probably
wait he's cute
he deserved it
are you married uh no no but I'm single
did a scientist make you in a lab can I
stick my tongue down your throat please
this is so inappropriate if the rolls
were reversed
not a fan of this scene anymore
why does she have this that's that's not
a jockstruck that's a g-string
see like this wouldn't fly today a joke
like that I know we should cancel
grown-ups too
Nick will save this movie
I think he has a concussion
yeah absolutely
well
if it is in Hollywood and the square Tim
Meadows do me a favor go like this I
think I got something in my teeth
what
dumb D I had to go with a kid good good
he's uh he's in school
probably a good knife he got the head
off a teddy bear imagine what it'll do
to me it's way it's wake up time all
right Grandma I'm off I really hope that
was a real Kmart worker
so my son bumpy told me he's going to
ask your daughter out on the date that's
a surprisingly beautiful shot
the color composition can we just take a
second
they both match either the hoses the
hoses
the whitest white guy in the world than
your little ball-headed boy I told him
how we used to roll with the ladies in
high school you know beep beep
I don't know what's going on do you know
what's going on
did you ever jump off suicide 35 at the
Quarry he always came up with a lame
excuse not to do it oh I can't I'm on my
period it'll attract sharks
this one is so much more red
yeah I was about to say this feels like
a sketch
whoa what an expensive kick
that's what I was thinking it's like wow
yeah it was a big big stunt for no
reason just it was great though
great man I want to smash his face
yeah me too yeah I hate that guy screw
him
yo Charlotte hold up hold up
question how would you like to spend the
first night of Summer
I remember he's like actually kind of
balding
[Music]
oh no oh my God
yo he's gotta put those Easter eggs back
in the basket dang
you just start with a burp then you
sniff for a sneeze you get that going
and that triggers a fart always what's
up with the school bus
Shaquille O'Neal hey McKenzie I heard
you assaulted somebody in there I didn't
insult anybody
I just choked out your brother
well he deserves it
oh my God recital five minutes we're
never gonna make it there right don't
get there on time because we're gonna
give you a far along presidential police
escort
holy [__]
[Applause]
that actually looks like a lot of fun
yeah
wonder how
whoa good stunt surprisingly good stunts
in this movie
oh yeah
[Applause]
our face her face we go throwing a few
hip-hop moves in there like this
is fun to dance I think this movie
empowers Women yeah
it's uh
it's a staple in the feminism movement
[Music]
one of these little kids got the joke no
peace
nice that sounds like something a middle
schooler would say
solo
what
this movie has officially transcended me
be quiet
Stone Cold Steve Austin I heard you've
been running around saying you could
take them in a fight
I wouldn't say that yeah you did this
morning in Kmart
small town gets around you know I want
you to stop making up lies about kicking
my ass or I'm up to set you straight
sure sure I'll see you around wow
wave knocking that guy out I swear to
God no you weren't this is grown-up talk
so bad
speak to me like that again in front of
my wife and kid I will brush your teeth
with a brick you just yelled at me I
don't yell at you no I'm just saying you
guys were in the bathroom you guys were
in the bathroom oh my God
please no
jeans busted princess oh bummer it's
broken like all your dreams
climb up the machine lean over the back
you're gonna see two pipes coming into
the top and there's gonna be a silver
button hit it a little bit push hard
yeah just push the button
[Laughter]
okay keep going
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is so disgusting and so we've
reached the
[Music]
school year
oh stop stop oh my God
this one is so weird what's the plot do
you know the plot heard our dad used to
come swimming here back in the day
they claimed to be on squeaky clean but
I think they were nuts
oh is that that's a drop spot or
something
oh hell yeah
okay that doesn't exist I live in a
small town shut up Sally this is great I
know I want it to be real I'm jealous
[Applause]
look at the party here one and two this
movie's okay
shut up
oh wait that's Ali mashaka she was on
Disney Channel what about these beers
man if we don't drink them they'll be on
to us and let's just dump them when no
one's looking then act like we're drunk
you're gonna get caught
[Music]
summertime
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I still do it buddy but you should
stop Taylor lot Taylor Lautner
Team Jacob quit perving on our ladies
and get back to your trailer hey you
tell a wolf boy I haven't been around
this many arrogant white college kids
since Eminem played Duke at least we got
into college skinny Danny Glover
he's very cool that's not really like a
disc though
that's rock paper scissors
I think it's over
commitment just gonna jump off of here
and then we'll leave I I I I can't
permit it but you did it in Twilight New
Moon
shaking them so mad
my brother's shaking
what what
I'm gonna kick this kid's ass but I need
like 11 to 15 minutes to stretch out
this is some of everything Taylor
lauter's doing I
will come back never
we've got a situation
[Applause]
[Music]
this is so stupid it's like a wolf pack
not that way
was there an elevator
way
you gonna make us jump
naked
you can like dive hitting the water that
way oh my God
oh
my God
David Henry
[Applause]
oh
broken bones
[Applause]
I was inside you
[Laughter]
what the hell just happened
I saw my dad's
oh that's sad they slashed our tires
these kids won't stop abusing us this
wasn't college kids
it was my son
dummy half in this thing for a minute
for what peer pressure I would do that
that's gonna be fun
[Applause]
why am I still rolling
not in the street no that's so oh my God
[Music]
oh my God
now
[Music]
oh no no baby
hahaha
[Music]
that's cold
Joe's over tired
nice
let's go Shaq they threw down saving the
day
[Music]
just some with a can of spray paint
looking like he was up to no good you
lied about the soup
[Music]
holy crap we've gotta find those fart
heads and we're gonna kill them
not each other
Taylor Lautner is the best part of this
movie I know he's so committed I I think
it's refreshing I
am
[Music]
that's impressive it makes me sad that
he's passed away oh that's right yeah he
just reminded me let's pretend I'm a
linebacker and I'm gonna come at you and
try and block it I'm a crazy doctor give
me that football
oh
my oh
I thought that was this rib cage you
literally crushed your son's dreams
you're late
Jimmy's back Steve Buscemi I almost said
douche me
officers do you guys want to stick
around have a drink with me you're
afraid of us leaving you alone with your
son aren't you I don't care he's got a
knife
it's a broken leg what was once one bone
is now two half bones is there anything
you can do about my wife staring at me
[Laughter]
are you taking your driver's test drunk
yeah
Hammer oh dude have you seen those old
townies from the Quarry today no I I
can't say that dude why
and they disrespected the crap out of it
oh no I can't have that
freaking the Hat next to you looks like
he needs it okay like I was Team Edward
but this movie made me Team Jacob
picking your driver's test while
intoxicated
say you rely there's five points yeah
Five Points that's it not bad
that's so mean
truth man it's life yeah
accurate
you say yesterday's history tomorrow's a
mystery maybe we go inside and search
the internet for funny videos of
squirrels water ski
that does sound fun
ah they're gonna Bond
stop looking at Becky's teeth
I really don't everybody looks this is
so unrealistic
you don't have to do this what a
okay you take these eyes we'll take the
yellow car guys
yeah
oh it's the Lonely Island crew here I
love him
why is this never ending at least the
guys in the car in front of us are
having fun
[Laughter]
basically he burp sneezes in Parts at
the same time
yeah
I think I just shot myself yeah
I thought it might be fun to have a
theme no the 80s the 80s the 80s that
was 70 years ago
why don't you ask Nancy Arbuckle to come
by for the get-together or do you prefer
the imaginary shower version ah
it's so mean I'm Kyle how do you know my
wife again there mud stuffing I've
worked her out this morning oh really I
worked her out this morning too pretty
good
laughs
all right
oh no this is awkward
sincere why is that awkward
[Laughter]
well let me give you a hint
you have brain damage
[Laughter]
I'm lost right now I'm sorry I had Andre
McKenzie doing he passed his test he
squeaked by we didn't check out any
soapy cheerleaders
bring the Hubba Bubba
what
why do you think that's me in what world
Greg come on Sally I really need to tell
you
yes
when we thinking about that all night
I'm kidding meet me by your mailbox at
11. why would I meet her by my mailbox
at 11.
get it Queen
I want to be here when I grow up
you won't you'll be the other girl
uh we're gonna try cardboard cones next
nice save you have such a nice smile
go out with me tonight before your
friends say I'm ugly sure no freaking
way
[Laughter]
I'm scared to sing in front of other
people
if you're scared that means you don't
got it that's so mean Bruce Springsteen
Born in the USA
who's Bruce Springsteen I stink as a
father
you
broke your son's leg she got over that
quick
[Music]
accurate
all you're doing is bringing up this
baby thing over and over are you you're
going through like a hormone situation
or something she's already pregnant
oh I forgot that was the storyline I'm
pregnant
what
money that's big brother yeah four kids
is the best what are you talking about
Prince I like that look on him I know
it's nostalgic we're old laments are
totally surrendered he's got a fanny
pack on now for God's sake why don't you
give it a shot
you got it I'll pull the string
ever say the party's over
here
Nanny secret table
yes honey how are you what's going on
that would have been funny if it was
actually Billy Idol at the party like in
The Wedding Singer oh yeah
as easy as making a free throw
ouch jeez
oh no no don't touch that okay you might
break it
how to do that I saw
[Music]
it
my boy's a genius
dad's also a genius what
what joke can you tell me a story
[Music]
[Applause]
what what would you do Greg
you don't want one slug no I'd abandon
the kid give him the iPad I would
appreciate it if he would stop trying to
manage me want me to stay away
alone
yo don't believe the hype boy
why did that remind me of Pete Davidson
you looking for this why does he look
good
I've sold them
you sell what'd you learn how to sell
Day Camp that's hot you're gay I mean
I'm gay but no there's no such thing as
gay cam man it was a joke I learned a
soul from my dad it was you went to KK
if I was like what's gay kid I thought
he said something else
[Applause]
[__] but
oh my gosh I'm just enjoying the water
[Applause]
a call back to the first movie Greg
oh yeah
I remember check out your girlfriend in
the Pat Benatar outfit
[Applause]
what have you done you little piece of
[__]
[Music]
ah that was amazing how'd you learn to
sing like that
no place all these children have musical
powers
and none of their parents have any idea
very important Leslie beat him up yeah
in a backwards cap let's go
who invited you guys
oh you gotta beat him up so you can show
your kid
um
there isn't a statute of limitations on
being
what'd you just say you and me are
fighting right now
oh here we go you ready for this not at
all
we're gonna do this because I gotta show
my son what's right
we do anything for our boys wouldn't we
lose for the kid yeah that's what I was
thinking be right on the chat I'll go
down like a sack of potatoes what are
you talking about
no don't hit me please the only reason I
picked on you was because I was afraid
of you oh my god what
hahaha
but if you ever
disrespect me or anybody I will hunt you
down
and I will slap you into a pile of
tattoos do you understand me yes I
understand you do you understand ah nice
walk away before I change my mind thank
you very much that was so underwhelming
I wanted to fight
he would have lost terrible I thought
they're gonna do like a fake fight
though you know what matter I tell you
what does he matter
these old town he's trashed our frat
house is that David Henry yeah oh my God
that's funny they didn't do it
me do it
I'll try and cover for him see dog
who's either
I guess nobody wants to leave this dump
because they're too busy sucking
[Applause]
we'll finish later you promise
laughs
he's so good we came here to kick some
old smelly
[Applause]
[Laughter]
whoa this is wild
[Music]
oh you're so hot
I will protect you for the rest of your
life
[Laughter]
thank you
I love he's got the dance moves
such a strange dream yeah you're a
traitor Boomer his name's name
oh it's scary yeah
it's Craig Craig
to us Greg's all the time don't worry
oh my God
will you work out Cinnabon we're done
who's back up baby those extras must
have been tired
dang
this happened
what will you raise my ninjas
he was raised by wolves I will make all
the Twilight jokes be surprised
thanks little girl it's a monkey
smart woman
smart little girl
oh my God that could have impaled him
okay get out here there's a deer
shiny penny
oops sorry I kicked your breath
[__]
that was like once upon a time in
Hollywood you know slow and then in the
last 20 minutes yeah
crazy violence yes Quentin Tarantino
took notes people today try to plan
things out so much
but don't think an unexpected child is
loved any less than one you planned for
the same thing it's okay
I'll make this between me and the baby
oh
he's growing up for the second time
need you to promise me one thing you'll
be the last one study ballet so I can
see that teacher as much as possible oh
my God I don't need no stinking ballet
teacher
act in the most beautiful woman in the
world yeah you are
watch your head in there
oh my God
I knew it I knew it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God he co-wrote it brilliant
work of Genius in my opinion
grown-ups too post-credits scene we
gotta we got it yeah we gotta stick
around for it is is there a post I hope
there's bloopers
there is no interesting or after the
credits
it's too bad you know who was missing
that I just realized
um Rob Schneider
I knew something was missing
cereal wasn't up to Snuff well Sally
take it away take it away Greg did you
get any of my Twilight wolf jokes please
don't edit them out they were good they
were
did you have you seen Twilight you know
what the word hilarious is just thank
you I was just saying good enough for
yourself you haven't seen Twilight her
new moon of course I've seen Twilight I
would say have you seen New Moon I've
seen new yes new moon so you know that
he was a wolf
yes the joke was okay I was just
checking because you were awful silent I
was like I don't know if he gets it it
was rib tickling
yeah
anyway
um riotus
I think you're lying and I think you
should react to all of the Twilight
movies on your channel anyway I would
say you had some
farcical side split in comedy going on
there Sally thanks thank you I just
wanted that compliment um
I think this movie was
did you talk did you cut out I think I
think I think there was a glitch there
was a listen
I really want to be in an Adam Sandler
movie so I I can't say anything bad
about it like there is nothing bad about
this movie
um
it might be the greatest movie we've
ever seen I think I'm just speechless
honestly I think it it
the callbacks okay in the script
that came back at the end I think we're
all
beautifully executed
um
Tarantino definitely took notes uh from
this film for his critically acclaimed
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
um
I think this broke boundaries for women
walls man
it did the glass ceiling broken
um
what did you think about it
I thought it was
fine
uh I I I
there are things about it that I liked
more than the first one
there are things that I like more from
the first one
you know it's a pleasure I definitely
still like the first one more I like the
Simplicity hangout Vibe of the first one
more yes this was
um
fascinating to me I like the kids stuff
the most when it came to the Father and
Son things anything with the children uh
the the college kids I actually thought
that was way more fun uh I think they
should stuff with the main cast
that's a great point I feel like the
college kids should have been in the
movie more like I feel like they should
have explored that uh element of it more
because they really were a great
standout
um in the movie also so many people in
this movie are from Disney Channel the
girl who ended up singing she was on a
Disney show
um the girl that gave them beers was on
a Disney show multiple Disney stuff like
Taylor Lautner I think was on Disney at
some point David Henry David Henry
Wizards Justin Russo and
like so many so many of those kids were
on Disney Channel I'm sure there was
more but Cameron Boyce obviously yeah
Saturday Night Live Adam Sandler's phone
book there was so many different people
but yeah I know I mean I thought it was
it there's something about both this
movie and the second one we're about 30
minutes it's like the 30 to 40 minute
Mark I'm just like I'm not paying
attention to the time anymore
yeah I think it something that happens
where I can just get
transcended into this
strange realm and tone where nothing is
ever fully there like that right the
comedy is is it's like it it makes me
laugh just enough to keep me entertained
and there's a lot of flat jokes but then
it is a lot of there's a surprising
amount of moments that are like yeah
that was actually really funny I like
this one more when it would would when
it had its times where it just embraced
how bizarre it can be and then yeah
because it would hold back on that where
it was like okay it's just this is not
this is weird but it's not fully bizarre
but when it goes fully bizarre that's
when I really it was when I thought the
comedy sang the highest in this film I
will say uh they really committed to
every
physical slapstick joke and uh that was
great I'm so glad that they uh didn't go
through with following up on the
breastfeeding storyline I was really
worried that would have went back up and
they didn't good happy for you
um
yeah I will say I was never bored and I
wasn't checking the time either in fact
I was like wow
how much more can happen and I was
excited to see what else was gonna
happen I don't ever want this journey to
come to a conclusion no it also made me
feel
lonely
um lonely yeah I'm like no I want to be
older with a family and like live near
all of my childhood not all of my
childhood friends but uh the good ones
and
care less yeah
really I think I'm better than them
technically you're a childhood friend of
mine David Henry being one of them
way better off than David
oh man Peak I think
um did you see his movie by the way
which one this is the year
no yeah yeah yeah that one yeah it was
yeah I thought I actually did a really
good job
okay yes I was pleasantly surprised but
I was like oh I don't have to I need to
watch it I need to watch it
um
he's got another movie coming up
I forget what it's called Boys of Summer
or something uh looking forward to that
it's got some good writers you know if
if they did a movie just about these
Frat Boys I would watch it well I felt
like that's what the movie actually had
like a excuse me I'm not yawning out of
boredom um I thought when this movie
yeah you are uh no please woman if this
movie taught me something it is to talk
down to you or sexualize do I need to
dance like a ballerina for you to not
yawn yeah and you got to take
responsibility for why I'm lashing out
at you I I think the movie had a real
a real kind of theme about growing up
when it was when it was
um pairing up the adults and the college
kids and or even just seeing the
parenting side of some of them like the
the the I mean some of it was just like
for gags like most of this movie some
weird gags but like Adams the journey
Adam Sandler's kids were specifically
going on
I thought that was heartfelt that kind
of reminded me more of
yeah that's when the movie seemed to
have like an actual heart about it yeah
weird jokes it was it was a really weird
because the first one's just like
hanging out and getting acquainted and
then friends rekindling and it's like a
simple hangout movie and then uh here
was uh just like it was it was a lot of
Randomness that was just stitched
together in the end and yeah like in a
lot more cameos you got Shaquille O'Neal
in here who was that's wild
Yeah Tim Meadows in here Taylor Lautner
really was the best part he was so funny
and he brought something different and
he was very engaged in what was
happening and uh like that's what I mean
he had this bizarre level of absurdity
yeah but he like leaned into it so far
that it it just worked like he really
fully committed and it was gold
energy he was so it was hilarious I
thought he was like I'm so proud of him
I was I thought it was so funny and uh
it made me want to see him do more
comedies because
sure he's fine in Twilight I guess he
has a podcast now he's definitely does
he acting again you actually following
Taylor Lautner's career
yeah because he said he has a dad bod
now it was what people were calling him
on social media and he got really down
about it so we started a podcast
no I yeah he also married someone named
Taylor so now they're both Taylor
Lautner Taylor Potter's dad bod typing
it in
no he's so cute
um I think he was just like he took a
break from Hollywood because he didn't
want to like have that his image was
very much
still like oh chiseled six-pack type
body and he didn't I don't think he like
he started to like resent I think
that type for him
and it's hard man
but you're right he should definitely do
more comedy he was in uh
something that I watched but
I think he took a break for a while I
would love to see him in more comedies
and then uh yeah we had Taylor Lautner
was good and then yeah I mean overall I
mean what more can you really say that I
like that they gave Salma Hayek actually
felt like a character
oh I will say she wasn't just mad this
whole movie because she was mad the
whole first movie but now I feel like
Adam Sandler was kind of like mean in
this movie like did you notice that yeah
I don't know why he was so mean in this
movie uh but I did like that they gave
Adam Sandler to be a chance to be a real
character this time around and so yeah
it didn't really feel like it was about
the four guys plus missing Rob Schneider
it was more about everyone and the kids
too yeah yeah there's some it was this
this is a strange world of grown-ups I
really feel like they've created a weird
world the lore we are invested in the
lore of grown-ups a lot of random plot
points that get brought up that don't
get brought back around a lot yes they
tried
um but no I mean the grain's goal is
just to make you like have some random
laughs and then for the most part it's
like I know what I'm walking into with
grown-ups I see why this movie manages
to walk away with a 53 audience score
out of a hundred thousand ratings
from an eight percent critic score
first one has ten percent
so you know but look up the box office
if he's getting paid like who cares get
that bread Adam Sandler and then you
know like him standing up to Stone Cold
Steve Austin for his kid like that kind
of [__] I like uh yeah I thought the
this movie managed to have more moments
that had actual heart
yeah then the first one did but the
first one somehow
sure
another weird disjointed strange feeling
film I feel like the first one gave me
more moments of
shock value
like genuine like this was going for
more gross out value this was yeah that
yeah um the first one also gave me this
weird like nostalgic feeling sure um
when they were at the lake house this
one I feel like it only Nostalgia I feel
like I felt was again like the moments
with the kids you know where they're
growing up and experiencing things I
experienced in school on a less
exaggerated level yeah but
but that was cute they definitely shined
in this movie is there a third
I don't know
I think we asked that in the last
the last video I'm gonna look it up
three
let's look it up
is grown-ups three coming out
oh okay there's no grown-ups three in
development right now
oh my God from three days ago from
Screen Rant
Sally we are in the right time to be
covering grown-ups too wait I thought
you said we were in this article for a
second I was about to like freak out no
no I'm just saying that what are the
odds we finally decided to do the sequel
and grown-ups three is being talked
about right now no way okay
um I wonder how they would handle
Cameron Boyce being gone you know
but that could give it some heart it was
just I can't imagine that would make me
cry
I don't know man I don't know I think
they should do the third one but make it
like uh a true Coming of Age story like
make it where they're like senior
citizens yeah make it like the Logan of
the grown-ups franchise
watching them deal with it as being
really really old and it should be like
they've Fallen apart as friends you know
ugh yeah something happens and they will
Fallen apart and then and then they have
to come together that's what tore their
marriage apart
divorce would do it yep yep divorce
that's a plot point
um I guess they repaired the
relationship Kevin James did
oh yeah you're right that was weird they
never came back around with his wife and
him having a weird like issue and then
also the mom thing like I didn't
understand that like what's so wrong
with him wanting to spend time with his
mom and watch soap operas because he's
avoiding his ball his wife he's avoiding
the relationship
beautiful
because he feels belittled because
apparently he's not good enough and she
just judges him
and he blamed her for why he escapes and
to have a conversation she took full
responsibility for it because women
to take full responsibility for why
their man escapes and doesn't talk to
them
I like space out halfway through it
that's very help me nerd of women and
then the last one it was so mean oh my
God it was so mean
and he made Adam Sandler made his wife
like
be married to the Blue Man
well it's funny too is oh that's right
his wife um I thought Steve Buscemi's uh
Cameo returning was fun she always Nails
it you know what I mean
I'm not gonna lie I forget who who that
actress is um I I she was like one of
the big Saturday Night Live characters
oh wait that's what I wanted to come
back around at the end was was her
little crush on him like she never gave
him the hubba bubba gum did she no but I
think she was not a threat on the poster
for grown-ups too
they're riding a roller coaster
[Music]
is that a real poster
the poster on IMDb the writing a roller
coaster
what why oh my god dude Maria Bello
Kevin James's wife her name looks like
your name if I didn't fully read it
it's Sally La mansof Lamont really
hey that's a crazy fun fact and you're
ignoring the [__] out of it no no I'm
looking at it you're right I am that
character I didn't get enough screen
time though which kind of sucks but what
is that woman's name
why can't I find it
I'm looking I'm still looking at the
poster
doesn't matter the woman was in there
why are they on a roller coaster that
doesn't make any sense because man this
movie's a roller coaster
wait
actually I observation Greg
they're not ever on a roller coaster in
this room
that is false advertising
and apparently
yeah apparently you can sue now for it
did you hear about that I know I'm
working on a Case right now
really
I'm doing what I can to survive out here
Sally
lawsuits are the only way even if that
means suing
um
yeah all right well we did it we watched
grown-ups too you're happy
I am energized you finally had it I am
so happy
that we got to ride this roller coaster
together Greg we did it we did it we
watched creatives too
are you ready for Pitch Perfect I am
ready to move on to Pitch Perfect Two
any day now well guys that one yes I'm
gonna ask the audience the third to you
guys do you prefer grown-ups too over
grown-ups one do you prefer this over
murder mystery too ah
I love the first murder mystery I love
the first one too that actually when we
were watching this it made me want to
watch the sequel because I really I
remembered I haven't seen it yet and I
love the first one I will watch the
second one
um yes the first one's great but guys
it's so good leave your thoughts down
below follow Sally on her YouTube
channel there's a wrong Link in the
description box and pin comment yes and
hey we'll talk with every one of you
guys
much sooner than later
peace out yes say bye Sally do your
woman dude bye
bye
go to my channel because yup why not
foreign